I was Gillian Jacobs here bring your in
we are all different
here bring her in yeah I'm gonna behave
myself now
yeah yeah I can't you know embarrass you
guys hello hello welcome Gillian Jacobs
you so much
hello what's going on they don't like it
you don't like lame is can you believe
that
I believe it oh no are you surprised
I love that movie he likes it we are we
doing a movie you're the musical either
okay yeah and one of us didn't know what
it was no I'm sorry Matt Farah yeah just
a former cage fighter Julian I but it's
been running on Broadway for decades I I
don't spend a ton of time on Broadway
um I go on my knees Claire I did that on
the way here I got my cardio in did you
see any marks music I think how is that
can draw that on okay all right they
mate they both looked at me like my I'd
like a that was from another planet when
I didn't know what that was do you have
a favorite musical Oh
give your West Side Story yes corn at
Allianz ever hear of what led you to the
Natalie Wood Google search yeah I told
them because he made a funny face he was
kind of making fun of me um Sam that I
liked West Side Story it's a good
musical I thought it's a great day for
Sondheim did the lyric why a funnel a
myth and being like I didn't make fun of
laymen but they're all awful all
musicals no wrong I'm not only musical
could you recommend a good musical sure
I love Stephen Sondheim musical Sweeney
Todd that's very bloody action hat the
Demon Barber of Fleet Street yeah you
know that that dance I don't know how
old I was but in elementary school my
music teacher our music teacher showed
us the play of that I think it scarred
me I were young yeah Bobby's cutthroats
yeah I'm down the shooting but that's
exciting
great I mean everyone that says musicals
are boring I would wanna know what was
disturbing I was watching that but I
don't like it I don't like to me sing
all their lines give a if they talk and
then break out into a strong now and
again I can live with it you don't like
opera well not only I don't like opera
you just don't like singing I like
singing under them but I wanted a
singing when watching a movie I want to
be singing there what if they did a
whole
four on Black Sabbath musical where it
was a story told through the songs of
Black Sabbath I'd love it the questions
I like in life that like I'm like oh wow
now to do a musical that's almost like
that yes spider-man wrong rocky all
rocky all wrong musical oh yeah exactly
the Winter Garden
oh the winter and and I see Matt I
actual robbery good I saw both I D I
shall despite a man I got it was like
the worst budgeted horrible I was like a
comic book movie with no budget it was
it was like a very cursed production
people get kept getting really hurt yeah
I was calling ya spend money on it
and it was brutal and then the other one
was the rocky I didn't I wasn't a big
fan of that okay the one that was okay
that I enjoyed and that other one the
rock one when they sing Rock of Ages I
didn't like that too much my life we got
these dirtbags with a bit going overseas
are doing it tongue out at your wife and
some of my gosh remember the second row
and I know it's part of the show and I'm
not I'm not like you know uh Peter uh
I'm not a insecure guy but you know
dirtbag some people tell you money let
me put your tongue out at my wife my to
say whoa whoa wait what are we doing out
a guy something there's like huh oh it's
part of the show are you like in choking
Constantine from American Idol or
whoever was I don't know I wasn't a big
fan
odds are the only one that I know that's
the musical version of the video yeah I
would be cold the wind is the wind Ricky
oh ah wicked
now normally you see the Rock of Ages
movie no so Jack Black no no I'm not
Ron's Tom Cruise Ali but how would he
room works retouches I told Julie and I
had the wulfing Prince where I go back
upstairs you mad bathroom because
there's number names our name is Delia
I'm so Gilly and I okay all right
absolutely every day if it's not a name
like Sam Jim or Matt I'm saying Gil
just call me Gil all right cool you know
you just need to try to figure out we
when we said lame is he didn't know what
it was and then when he saw it he was
like oh I know that but that's how you
say that
do ya right unless well done and you
would say I would think if I had to pick
I think the time I left would be the
bully that's guy guess you're like you
have a problem is
oh man spicy rice I need normalcy
Jimmy took over to see how we proceed
all right yeah I didn't feel over there
it's a phenomenal talent great thank you
sir oh yeah really great I get to turn
people off and on really you hope hour
after hour yeah but I realize it was in
charge of the googling on this operation
that would be Adrian who I don't know
where you I think you want to get mad at
how about some only sweaty little
Italian guy on popping where you walk
all the way up here you like listen
around 36 floors I would love a debacle
I jumped in the elevator as you seen
when you got nano later there's no
button no let me outside
yep hmm hi dad it's me - I did it wrong
don't wind up Bernard is a nice the
lady's in there they showed me how to
get out of there like I was going up and
they was working so I didn't want to
interrupt them like I swooned later I'll
get Oakland in a psycho look I go I'm
sorry girls I go I'm new here don't want
to this elevator just a Twilight Zone
where am I going
so then they directed me here it's very
cool no no it's an eco-friendly building
so they are conserving energy by only
having a lease that was everyone okay
that's a theory I think behind it take
some longer with you they don't go
faster it's not for us it's for the
environment it doesn't help the
environment I'm not hurting the
environment to use an elevator what the
[ __ ] is wrong with people if it's you
yes it is it's mechanics it's stuff all
topics like what gas or something -
probably other note on electricity right
electricity that's really hard stuff to
make electricity they realize right
surrounded by radiation in space with
the Fox role-p term you got to pay more
attention to your carbon footprint it's
getting ridiculous
you should get those Tesla made of solar
panels for your apartment or home or car
that's right I can't I have a I have a
condo but if you're allowed to in New
York
oh you should talk to the condo board
that was fun I like
trying to get Tesla made I can't get my
[ __ ] window cracked it don't work
those solar panels and I can't say what
people come up to my freaking house that
that makes me want to be in like a gated
community ISM but it was laterally
reason because I like well there they
walk up and down the block on the island
and there's people that just ring my
bell
there's a person of that I just put my
three-year-old to the nap and I was
trying to get a little snap in two
before they get my other kids from
school and my wife was out and the
doorbell rings and I go there's two guys
and I'm like yo guys I go I go really
I go I go buddy oh no no we're not
selling anything what is the new
realtors in the neighborhood and we want
introduce us l-like oh really like you
want to introduce yourself like oh I
want to jiu-jitsu squad two of them I'm
gonna where do you live I'm gonna come
to your bail later tell you about my arm
locks I got it like that I really by the
way my you gotta make sure those guys
are legitimate real estate guys and not
casing houses yeah yeah I don't think
probably him telling about them the
jujitsu might have deserted that they
were chasing that's okay I'm going to
say that come on
Iona to jiu-jitsu studios yeah don't
mess with me I just a frightening cage
for living guys seriously get another
daughter go ring their Bell it probably
was a Wet Bandits scenario it's all
tonight
homeowners counting cars era thankless
or not
haven't had a lot coffee this morning I
didn't have that exciting walk through
Times Square to really like get the
adrenaline flow you a coffee person I
love coffee you want what we can get one
for you Madame Jeunet be on it man a
little while to get us coffee but if you
do although we'll have one brought for
you that would be delightful when we
want how would you like your cream and
sugar listeners a little cream and sugar
Oh what's going on Sam they're gonna go
get it
there's somebody getting your call thank
you so much idly what's going on love
season two yes that's so true oh yeah
I'm supposed to promote my television
show that one that's like one of them
come on on March 10th so Friday and you
also have season three is already good
too you have another season you're going
to start shooting we start shooting I
think next week season 3 yes how can we
have a treated since November I just
didn't really feel like doing social
Media you got sick of it yeah it's kind
of creepy how do you know why I came it
existed it never tweeted in three is
that sound creepy area why haven't you
answered ninja your number no expunged
here like you preview interviewing
services go back to look at their tweets
and see what you have talking louder but
you haven't no usually did you get sick
of it or is it negative stuff you got
bored I just kind of looked over the
last year and a half I feel like I've
just been growing tired of it but you
know I have the show coming out so I'm
sure you know it's important to let
people know the show's back so I'm a
tweet again really I like doing really
Ansett promote if you already got season
three like Rihanna it's in the bag yeah
I'm sure Netflix would like it if I
would maybe talk about it on my social
media crazy followers on there what's
her followers Jimmy I don't know I'm not
always you guys I don't know about it
you said it right away I do it memorized
all my social media exactly how come in
October of 2013 I don't know I I dunno
it's just written down yeah okay a lot
of people I don't know you reach a lot
of people I don't have millions of
followers we did tweeting more citizen I
mean I wish I got off that thing - you
don't we oh I'm done with Twitter you
know Jimmy yeah Matt's office I listen I
keep you with negativity in my life
yeah alright you know I don't have the
ABS I used to have one oh no I don't
want to surprise you Gil no I like it
you can call me new oh she's our you
call me Gil a shirt I used to fight you
know back like you know they just
excusal
fight billion when I got a championship
ten years ago a bit edgy when I got the
belt anyway but the point is on Twitter
I don't know today's our UFC unfiltered
that's the show I do with Jimmy the
podcast
you just plug yourself as a former
champion a lot yeah once I said oh my
god can i push it yeah of course no it
was my trainer - look your abs that's
why not is so I'll be like yeah today
sure we got GSB it's me and Jim know we
can have a good time I mean I look at my
Twitter like AHA fatty you
we won't know up where they just are
they just assume they make it they made
an ass out of you and me yeah right they
did that's right they certainly did did
you get that with Drogo office
no you couldn't evil mayhem on a mat
sorry handle it difficult and see the
way they are speaking to you know wasn't
anything it wasn't like um anything like
that no I just didn't I don't know just
kind of grew tired of it but I posted an
Instagram photo recently I had posted
one in a long time so maybe I'll do that
I don't know yeah there's lots of things
that could be on your plate going sure
I've been trying to read more you know
what are you reading I I loved
Agatha Christie miss Teresa kids I've
been rereading some Paro mystery oh
really my hardy boy Josh you are the
toilet finances yes that's the one I
entertain sure is my legs are crossed
man coughing used to [ __ ] with her legs
crossed she would sit down a [ __ ] and
she would touch you would sit and cross
her legs perfectly like the Queen that's
not good [ __ ] what did you have a
squatty potty no just on the ball she
told me that I mean I need she just told
me she was I was shocked what's the
point though I don't know I don't know
why you felt more comfortable I could
never I don't thank you so much my
coffee is here dear listeners my progeny
is here I need a good bracing your heels
to the floor
oh I don't like up on a wall no agent
well enough room thank God no I like to
get my heels down good push you to get
our hernia doing that Android yeah you
could get some hemorrhoids going don't
push so hard change your diet see you
reading Agatha Christie what's a good I
get to Christie book I've never read one
ah are they really good mystery - they
really mysterious well the dream totally
serious are very scary easy to figure
out well you're very clever man thank
you you're the scary I said they're not
very scary it's I liked watching the
also the TV movies we made of them of
the Poirot ones with David Suchet my
mother and I would rent them from the
library when I was kid that was a really
fun Friday night sounds good my mom
didn't really let me
here let me out of her sight very often
so it was a lot of at home rentals from
the library for me I'm at Murder She
Wrote as into that no no I couldn't
stand it all that I didn't like her you
know
she starred in a production of Sweeney
Todd she's appeared in a lot of musicals
as a literary you really don't like her
I guess regard the musical on hand she
was a Murder She Wrote I don't know why
I didn't like that damn show
it was awful that was wife Donna come on
guys guys guys guys
well I never saw it I'm not gonna
disparage it she liked about that old
out was an old show yeah she's going
around on a bike and solving writing
balls writing mysteries and writing
stories and saw the old lady and I think
you're going to like these I guess at
Christmas everybody knows everything
your lady bothering everyone but us I
used to run those reruns like before way
before as for you like in the early 90s
mid-90s us I used to run Murder She
Wrote oh all the time
it's an ad show the right what you
thinking I didn't take it to the Google
machine I know every show come on yeah
we're getting going long run it till
somebody logged in it's not you three
years for 2000 issue she's got to be
pushing let's look it up thank you for
the Google I'm gonna get to jt6 Angela
Lansbury man you won I won you won
should we all live so long yes that's a
DBE game of the British Empire that's a
high honor go dying back there laughing
a little too hard
gentlemen and the only woman in the room
right now Bruno I'm right I was he met
along in a well dream career and look at
all of you have two Oscar nominations
yeah no I would think not
11 MGM films excuse you I'll say this
she was definitely been active for a
long time she's a messing she's a bad
actress I just didn't like that you let
me go back to her thing is I would see
her is she's still acting 91 that's
pretty amazing
come on give it up for you should book
her on this show
should natural fit you know doc dr. Ruth
we had I couldn't wait to talk to dr. if
she was [ __ ] awful why was innocent
shitty I'm writing you about I thought
she would actually be an open eye look
about about now I hope you guys would be
uh I know right hello pride I try to
honor my sexy she's like I talked to
your fella best about that I'm like [ __ ]
you I just want to talk about she's so
old I was nice to her I can't yell at an
old lady right yella yella Angela
Lansbury right here I'm right you know
you don't let baby Jam I would never
pulley an old person I would I pull
you'll be good good right right
egg salad refuse with that except behind
their online right I have an egg critter
account I do like that old people yeah
and I fully able over eighty that's
great
this is you I you have any idea could
you do a ton of like indie movies I do
did you have any idea that don't think
twice would be like one has a people saw
yeah yeah it's big I was helping after
so many nobody kind of came and went to
theaters one weekend
goodbye no it was really nice you know
Mike Birbiglia promoted the hell out of
that movie and it actually played in
theaters for months so it was really
nice change of pace for me yeah
because I was going to say it was really
good but I'm assuming that in your mind
most of the movies that people don't
have anything to do with each other yeah
movie being good and people seeing it
yeah you need promotion you need support
and so thankfully that one people really
watch so without the one mic wrote and
directed about improv group yeah oh I
didn't see that yes everybody except for
Jim you thought you loved it what's that
enough Sweeney Todd we're we doing you
loved my independent film about an
improv troupe trying to make a new
albeit a problem one your low yeah I
know it's good he said you know the
parallels between MMA and improv I ever
knew so are you an amazing much any of
those you Ultimate Fighter change you
have the thing in a cage with it I know
the cage I know it how are not your feet
like an in-progress not as much as I
would say Pro Wrestling man would you
feel happy we do all that I and we get
it we are your friend
and the pro-wrestling are we now go
there you're going to be really excited
because in the season three of love
there may or may not be a little pro
wrestling really yes
wrestlers doing the pro wrestling I
offered up some names of people you know
I don't know who they've cast you had
names yes I know that I know people yeah
have you ever considered pro wrestling
however I use unless they bring back
[ __ ] wrestling I do jump on somebody's
like how tall at about five six five
powerful you could take I'm not saying I
won't beat any other answers in a real
tight supply then wait a second don't
care I was distracted of me beating up
the one of the best in the world
oh now you know what they call me chubby
now that's even when I'm in shaving of
the best heads along a little better go
there right now and that's called it's
an official Betty GU and I'm just I look
at this this never gets old
I want you tomorrow there's I don't I
don't know what's happening while we're
watching it is being put on mat beating
George st. Pierre for the championship
you know what it's done at WrestleMania
you know I mean a hundred percent you're
right with that how old were you there
I was [ __ ] bags bags make me feel
great that was in April that's exactly
three months
yeah I've been partying on carousel
we're gonna wing it out of you that was
ten years ago you look great and you
don't look great watch I know
thank you so much I don't know that I'm
hungry people online you look great
thank you so much thank you that's why I
wear black so it makes me look very
slimming
thank you but um yeah that made me feel
good watching human everything in the
cage
you know sometimes but I you know I
moved on was there a man in chapter or
was there a moment where you realize I
got a stop there was one thing that
stuck when you're fighting it has to be
you have to be all in or all out because
it's it's a sport but the dangerous
sport it's it's the hurt business you're
in it to take the other guy out and he's
there to do the same to you you know by
whether it strikes or getting it on
without the brake or getting guys
strangling a guy it's a fight you know
so I remember when anybody used to
mention my name if they wanted to fight
me is something I used to take it
personal and then that was like my goal
well I remember I was literally I
thought I heard some guys mentioned me
in an interview and I was literally
about to take my kid to the park and I
didn't really give a [ __ ] I took like
that's all my guys wrong I'm not it's
that magic same reaction that should be
my priority yes guys I got a kick and I
didn't really I was like kind of
nonchalant about something I maybe I
should get out of it you know that's the
kind of sweet moment to realize yeah
yeah it's yeah for me it would be I was
laying on the mat with a bunch of [ __ ]
on the back of my legs and I realized it
was mine it was time to go home that is
a good way to get cat diarrhea in the
rain it is a new rule in MMA by the way
that is fecal matter is too true
if fecal matter is present whoever did
it is disqualified whoa because there
was a case of a guy who should have
pants last year as a tactic that was it
nobody tell you what it was right no he
just got punched you show your hand to
be [ __ ] in the ring it should be an
email that it would you do a sort of
thing where you stop eating a certain
number of hours before the fight to make
sure you don't have to pee or poop for
free though and funny about that so
funny said that goes after I especially
when I used to fight at 155 which was
somebody that when I was 29 but I
remember my instructor master Hensel
Gracie he'd come out to me and I'm
eating a lot the day of the fights I'm
saying like try cereal equals man either
brazilian guy goes you stop doing that
shitty I go I'm hungry so he goes she
ever see pit bulls when they fight the
[ __ ] flies out of their ass oh my god
whoa so I put down the the another chick
makes my
yeah cuz that when I realized what I do
theater I would be worried I have to pee
in the middle of the place I stopped
drinking our water you so much how long
would your play be an hour and a half
stop yeah I'm sorry I see on the screen
about you showing that aren't you guys
should yeah I'm so in the ring I was
like a reaction you're talking about
stop is not talking about theater
exactly have that to stop it's a 90
minute play and you pee that you'd have
to pee right before do you go right
before you do something like this
constant yes I pee all the time so
covert before I would stop drinking
water a couple hours before and then
just pee as many times as I could before
hand yes a weird thing like II was
during a flight you love that don't you
know just I am a big fight against
choked out proceeds to poop all over the
kid
as I'm Cooper like a child like a star
the word poop like haha [ __ ] so if you
want to play we're going to be right
before you take off oh yeah like it's
psychological yeah yeah so worse tiny
letters yeah you watch you watch your
highlights at home because you said you
felt good when you saw it like if I
watch my highlights now you're on a down
day I'm like well I mean now Sarah into
YouTube and the UFC fight pass so I'm
always plugging my team I'm always
processing but um yeah you know sure
do you watch episodes a lot that I would
be like I nailed that one I I have a
hard time the first time I watch
anything I'm in it's just sort of
recoiling in horror but I watch some
things I've never seen that I'm in and
other things like I would never miss an
episode of community I'd watch those the
week they came out I've seen all of the
love episodes but I get too nervous to
watch them before they come out you know
because we with Netflix you're done four
months before it goes online but I get
too nervous to watch it please just let
it sit for a while and then eventually
get to it yeah I find that I I can't
watch stuff but I like I'll listen to
all radio clips that was really quite
like you know like this times where
somebody will send me a clip and I can
really enjoy it has to be old not not
that it can be recent it's just not in
the moment but like some of the older
stuff like if don't listen to this part
I can enjoy just separately when you're
a little distant from it to lambier is
it easier to watch that community
because there was like a whole yeah yeah
it's supposed to love where it's like
you're responsible for a lot of the load
yeah a lot of the pupu then that's the
industry jargon Jim place I mean a lot
of the load yeah I don't know what that
mean area no no anything I carry a lot
of things in the show yeah her
character's a lumberjack you see
Michelle who caused this you know who
co-stars with you Paul rust is his name
okay and what's the show about
it's about the two of us we meet in the
first season my character has a lot of
issues she's grappling with alcohol drug
addiction and sex and love addiction and
he is a kind of a people pleaser with
repressed rage so on the surface we are
real opposites but what do you know we
attract hey man
so the second secret is more of us
actually starting to date I'm trying to
think of who you would know that's on
the show Bobby Lee has a record of Bobby
plays one of my co-workers on our show
how was he to work with because whenever
we've had him in studio he ends up
having a panic attack and runs out oh
yeah he the first season after every
scene he'd be like they're gonna fire me
they're going to fire me they're going
to fire me so I have to talk him down
and everything but he's really great so
it's a fun person to have around and
he's got a great episode the second
season there's a lot of Bobby Lee so
he's awesome and Paula Pell who wrote on
SNL for years and years plays my boss on
the show so that was awesome a lot of
really great comedy people on on it and
trans think of who if what other
stand-ups are add David Spade's in the
second season alone and who would who
would Kim know Sam come on Hank probably
a lotta commas very varied interests yes
what's your most surprising interest
well not that I like women cut right
even and that's a little bit of a loose
step no I don't know that said I don't
know I talked about all that's none of a
choice approach yeah no I know I'm
wondering if there's something you've
never really shared something sweet Oh
heartwarming I'm sorry come on sometimes
um sometimes I go down to the Children's
Hospital I just donate time that he
literally has never done that Wow
I have it going to call you yeah Weah
see we have to wrap up with gilliam idea
that's it because you have a depressed
oh did you date opposite guys from who
you are or do you have personality hmm
good question
uh if I have a shot oh uh sure cool all
right good good stuff not easy at least
resistant that will keep me going to the
next interview so great a lot of season
two premieres Friday on Netflix season
one was awesome I really you're amazing
and everything you do so it's off to the
shows of success and congratulations and
check-in isn't it great it's up and
people can just watch it whatever they
want the whole thing you have to give a
[ __ ] about the premiere date Friday
watch it one i watch all and if you
didn't watch it before you can still
watch season one don't catch up let me
be really quick I know you got to go but
it's called
I'm not a daddy well it's a cold love
and you're talking about a lot of
comedians in there why is that
I got David Spade you said you said
hobby we it's got a humorous bent to it
you're going I see now a comedy about
lot of comedy
there's what a pleasure good we'll be
right back you two
taking a break bread rack